It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然保持稳定。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会过期的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Try to picture an apple. For most people, that's easy. The word conjures up an image in their mind's eye of a round red fruit with a brown stem, maybe a green leaf on the top. But for people with Aphantasia, it's impossible. Trying to picture an apple or anything else brings up nothing but essentially a blank screen. Today we're going to talk with one of the world's leading experts on Aphantasia
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。试着想象一个苹果。对大多数人来说，这很容易。这个词会在他们的脑海中浮现出一个圆圆的、红色的、带有棕色果梗的水果形象，顶部可能还有一片绿叶。但对于患有“心盲症”（Aphantasia）的人来说，这是不可能的。试图想象一个苹果或其他任何东西，只会浮现出一片空白，就像屏幕没开一样。今天，我们将与世界领先的心盲症专家之一进行交流，
or the inability to visualize things in one's mind's eye. about what scientists are learning about this recently identified condition. What causes Afantasia? How common is it? How do you reliably measure a person's inner experience, like the ability to form mental images? What effects might Afantasia have on people's lives, from memory to creativity to mental health?
或者说，无法在脑海中进行视觉化想象的人。我们将探讨科学家们对这一近期才被识别出的病症有哪些了解。是什么导致了心盲症？它有多普遍？你如何可靠地衡量一个人的内心体验，比如形成心理意象的能力？心盲症会对人们的生活产生什么影响，从记忆力到创造力，再到心理健康？
And what can studying Afantasia tell us more broadly about how the human mind works? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology. flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Joel Pearson, a professor in the School of Psychology and Director of the Future Minds Lab at the University of New South Wales in Australia. He is a cognitive neuroscientist whose research explores intuition, the human imagination, affantasia, and the psychological impact of artificial intelligence. He's a
研究心盲症能让我们更广泛地了解人类思维是如何运作的吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人 Kim Mills。今天的嘉宾是 Joel Pearson 博士，他是澳大利亚新南威尔士大学心理学院教授，也是未来思维实验室（Future Minds Lab）的主任。他是一位认知神经科学家，其研究领域涵盖直觉、人类想象力、心盲症以及人工智能对心理的影响。他是一位
sought-after speaker, author and writer who has published dozens of peer-reviewed research articles and whose work has been covered by media outlets, including The New Yorker, ABC Australia, and the New York Times. Dr. Pearson, thank you for joining me today. My pleasure, Kim. Great to be here. I described Afantasia in the introduction a moment ago, but let's start with a little more context in history for our listeners. So can you tell us more about what exactly if Aphantasia is and how long have signed? Scientists recognized it as a distinct condition. Absolutely, yeah.
备受追捧的演讲者、作家和撰稿人，发表过数十篇同行评审的研究论文，其工作被《纽约客》、澳大利亚广播公司（ABC Australia）和《纽约时报》等媒体报道。Pearson 博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。Kim，这是我的荣幸，很高兴来到这里。刚才在介绍中我描述了心盲症，但让我们先为听众提供一些背景和历史。您能详细告诉我们心盲症到底是什么，科学家们将其识别为一种独特的病症有多久了？当然，可以。
So it's generally considered the inability to visualize. So sometimes people will use a phrase imagination, but that's a very broad phrase that people get confused with creativity and other things. So it's really the inability to visualize, typically visual mental imagery. And we'll unpack some of the other senses a little bit later. So mainly it's talked about or referred to as the inability to visualize. So when you think about, like you said in the introduction, what an apple might look like, for someone like me who has mental imagery, I have this sort of momentary glimpse of a conscious experience of the colors and shapes of the apple. And I see it and then it fades and it comes back. So people who don't have any mental imagery won't have that. They will have a black on black experience. There are all kinds of different descriptions. We hear about it like a black velvet on, you know, with a black background. So there's almost. something there but not quite. So that's sort of typically refers to the voluntary. I should also
通常认为它是指无法进行视觉化想象。有时人们会用“想象力”这个词，但这是一个非常宽泛的词，人们常把它与创造力和其他事物混淆。所以它实际上是指无法进行视觉化，通常是指视觉心理意象。稍后我们会详细拆解其他感官。所以它主要被称为无法进行视觉化。当你像我在介绍中所说的那样思考苹果的样子时，对于像我这样有心理意象的人来说，我会瞬间闪过一个关于苹果颜色和形状的意识体验。我看到了它，然后它消失了，又会回来。所以那些没有任何心理意象的人就不会有这种体验。他们会有一种“黑上加黑”的体验。我们听过各种各样的描述，比如像是在黑色背景上的黑色天鹅绒。所以那里似乎有什么东西，但又不太真切。所以这通常指的是自愿的。我还应该
mention voluntary creation of the mental image. So we can also dive into voluntary involuntary, involuntary. And interesting, we've known about sort of the existence of Afantasia for quite a long time. So Francis Galton published his paper in about 1883, which has become very famous since then, where he had his friends and colleagues come in and sort of describe what they had for breakfast, what was on the breakfast table, he discovered that some people could not recall or not recreate that mental image. And so he concluded that some part of the population has no ability to visualize. Then sort of over the, you know, many, many decades since then, you know, there's a few papers which touched on this idea of having no mental imagery, but it really wasn't until 2015,
提到心理意象的自愿创造。我们稍后也可以深入探讨自愿与非自愿。有趣的是，我们对心盲症的存在已经了解很长时间了。弗朗西斯·高尔顿（Francis Galton）在 1883 年左右发表了他的论文，从那时起就变得非常出名。他在论文中让朋友和同事进来，描述他们早餐吃了什么，早餐桌上有什么，他发现有些人无法回忆起或无法重现那种心理意象。因此他得出结论，部分人群没有视觉化能力。在那之后的几十年里，有几篇论文触及了这种没有心理意象的想法，但直到 2015 年，
where a paper gave it the name, A Fantasia, coined this new name for it. And then there was a few media articles about it. And then the idea kind of just took off in the sort of people's minds and I almost said imagination. Yeah, it's sort of just people started identifying with it and thinking about it. And it's spread. And so everywhere I go now and speak, you know, people know about it or people are discovering about it. People are really fascinated about these individual differences in the way, the format of our thoughts, things like this, how, you know, some people can think in pictures, other people can't, what does that mean,
一篇论文才给它起名为“心盲症”（Aphantasia），创造了这个新词。随后出现了一些关于它的媒体报道。这个概念在人们的脑海中——我差点又说成“想象力”了——迅速传播开来。是的，人们开始认同它并思考它。它传播开了。所以现在无论我走到哪里演讲，人们都知道它，或者正在发现它。人们对思维方式、思维格式的个体差异非常着迷，比如有些人能用图片思考，有些人不能，这意味着什么，
how their brain's different, what does it mean to their everyday life, their creativity, their relationships, their jobs, all these questions have been popping up. So it's, you know, in the last sort of decade or so, the topic has just gotten so much attention and so much, yeah, scientific and general public attention. Well, let me ask you how common is a Fantasia. I mean, for those of us who don't have it, it's very hard to imagine not how much. having a mental image. You try to stop yourself. If I say, don't think about an elephant, you're going to think about an elephant and you'll see it. One thing I'll say up front is that the
他们的大脑有何不同，这对他们的日常生活、创造力、人际关系、工作意味着什么，所有这些问题都不断涌现。所以，在过去十年左右的时间里，这个话题受到了极大的关注，无论是科学界还是公众。那么，我想问您心盲症有多普遍？我的意思是，对于我们这些没有心盲症的人来说，很难想象没有心理意象是什么感觉。你试着阻止自己。如果我说“不要去想大象”，你肯定会想到大象，并且会看到它。首先我要说的是，
main way to measure mental imagery or Afantasia at scale is using a questionnaire, and that's called the vividness of visual imagery questionnaire. And using that technique, we think the, it's sort of four or five percent of the population. One of the downsides, I'm a huge fan of questionnaires, but one of the downsides is that the questionnaire like this is really examining two things at once. It's examining someone's actual visual mental imagery, but it's also examining how they decide or their criteria for giving a number to that mental imagery. So you and me, Kim, could have the exact same mental imagery of a sunset, and you could decide to give it a two, and I could decide to give it a four or five. And that's our internal criteria, our metacognition
衡量心理意象或心盲症的主要规模化方法是使用问卷，这被称为“视觉意象生动度问卷”（Vividness of Visual Imagery Questionnaire）。使用这种技术，我们认为大约有 4% 到 5% 的人口患有此症。缺点之一是——虽然我非常喜欢问卷——但这种问卷实际上是在同时考察两件事。它既在考察一个人的实际视觉心理意象，也在考察他们决定给该心理意象打分时的标准。所以，你和我，Kim，可能对日落有着完全相同的心理意象，但你可能会决定给它打 2 分，而我可能会给它打 4 分或 5 分。这是我们的内在标准，是我们对自身评估的元认知。
of our assessment of that. what we're also finding is that some people who have a Fantasia have lived their lives thinking that the idea of mental imagery and visualization was a metaphor. And so they assumed that everyone had the same experience. And so when they fill out a questionnaire, they tend to score it quite highly because they don't realize what mental imagery can be in others. And so we found quite a few of these people that when you then just talk about or give them a little video about what imagery can be, that it can be this conscious visual experience.
我们还发现，一些患有心盲症的人一生都认为心理意象和视觉化的概念只是一个比喻。因此，他们假设每个人的体验都是一样的。所以当他们填写问卷时，他们往往会给出很高的分数，因为他们没有意识到心理意象在其他人身上是什么样的。因此，我们发现了相当多这样的人，当你和他们交谈或给他们看一段关于意象可能是什么的短视频，让他们知道这可以是一种有意识的视觉体验时，
They're genuinely shocked and they all often readjust their numbers in the questionnaire. They're reported downwards. So for those reasons, I suspect that, you know, the estimate might be a bit higher than the 5%, maybe in the 6, 7, 8% range. But we haven't been able to use our more objective lab-based techniques to assess visual imagery on a large-scale study yet. Now, you've come up with a different technique, right? I mean, it's not just self-reports on a questionnaire.
他们会感到非常震惊，并且经常会重新调整问卷中的分数，报告的分数会下降。因此，基于这些原因，我怀疑这个比例可能比 5% 要高一些，可能在 6%、7% 或 8% 的范围内。但我们目前还无法使用更客观的实验室技术在大规模研究中评估视觉意象。那么，您已经提出了一种不同的技术，对吧？我的意思是，这不仅仅是问卷上的自我报告。
You have another method of measuring Afantasia. Can you talk about that? Yeah, we've actually developed three different methods over the years. And the first one that sort of, you know, that was pivotal in my personal journey getting to study mental imagery was using a visual illusion called binocular rivalry, which, as it sounds, is rivalry between the images, going into each eye. So if I put up a hand in front of one eye, my brain, my one eye, my right eye will see my hand, the other eye will see you on the computer screen. And that puts my visual
您还有另一种衡量心盲症的方法。能谈谈那个吗？是的，多年来我们实际上开发了三种不同的方法。第一种对我个人研究心理意象的历程至关重要，它使用了一种名为“双眼竞争”（binocular rivalry）的视觉错觉。顾名思义，这是进入每只眼睛的图像之间的竞争。如果我把一只手放在一只眼睛前，我的大脑——我的一只眼睛，我的右眼——会看到我的手，而另一只眼睛会看到电脑屏幕上的你。这让我的视觉
system into this state of conflict, hence rivalry. And when you sort of balance those images out, you get these beautiful vacillations and oscillations of consciousness between whatever's going to one eye versus the other. And so we use that visual illusion block and rivalry to study consciousness in its own right. But I discovered many years ago, that you could actually use the illusion as a way to measure mental imagery. So how it works is, let's say we have a binocular setup. So we have a red pattern and a green pattern, one going to each eye. We just get participants to try and imagine one of those patterns. So they imagine, say, the red pattern, then we just briefly flash on this binocular ivory illusion. And we found that
系统进入了一种冲突状态，也就是竞争。当你平衡这些图像时，你会看到意识在进入每只眼睛的图像之间产生美丽的波动和振荡。因此，我们利用这种视觉错觉——双眼竞争——来研究意识本身。但我多年前发现，你实际上可以利用这种错觉作为衡量心理意象的方法。它的工作原理是，假设我们有一个双眼设置。我们有一个红色图案和一个绿色图案，分别进入每只眼睛。我们只是让参与者尝试想象其中一个图案。比如他们想象红色图案，然后我们短暂地闪现这个双眼竞争错觉。我们发现，
what they imagine tended to be what they see. In other words, the content of their mental imagery, their visual imagery was biasing the way they saw this visual illusion. You imagine red, you see red. You imagine green, you see green. And over a number of trials, that turned out to be a nice way to measure the sort of sensory strength of visual imagery. So that was the first method. We've sort of developed two other methods. Another way to do it is using emotional mental imagery. So we have people come into the lab and they wear a little thing on their finger, which measures skin conductance. So just sort of the levels of micro sweat on the skin. Then we have them read out these kind of scary scenarios. They're swimming in the ocean and
他们想象的内容往往就是他们所看到的。换句话说，他们心理意象的内容正在偏向他们看待这种视觉错觉的方式。你想象红色，你就会看到红色。你想象绿色，你就会看到绿色。经过多次试验，这证明是一种衡量视觉意象感官强度的不错方法。这是第一种方法。我们还开发了另外两种方法。另一种方法是使用情感心理意象。我们让人们来到实验室，在手指上戴一个小东西，测量皮肤电导。也就是皮肤上微汗的水平。然后让他们读出一些可怕的情景。比如他们在海里游泳，
a dark shadow moves underneath them. Something bumps their foot. They look back at the beach and people are screaming, you know, and the shark gets closer and closer. Or they're rock climbing and their fingers start slipping. And we find that this skin conductance response, which is kind of a a way to measure stress or anxiety, if you have mental imagery goes up as they're reading these stories. If people are doing the experiment who have a Fantasia, you see more or less a noisy flat line. So there's a difference in that sort of emotional or stress response. If you show both those groups just scary images, pictures on the screen, you see more or less the same response. So it does seem to be just the role of imagery in translating the words into ideas into a visual imagery that drives more emotion.
一个黑影在他们下方移动。有什么东西撞到了他们的脚。他们回头看海滩，人们在尖叫，鲨鱼越来越近。或者他们在攀岩，手指开始打滑。我们发现，这种皮肤电导反应——这是一种衡量压力或焦虑的方法——如果你有心理意象，当你阅读这些故事时，反应就会上升。如果患有心盲症的人参与实验，你会看到一条嘈杂的平线。所以这种情感或压力反应存在差异。如果你给这两组人看恐怖图像，屏幕上的图片，你会看到大致相同的反应。所以这似乎只是意象在将文字转化为想法、转化为视觉意象的过程中，驱动了更多情感。
And we'll see a bit later that this emotional response is one of the sort of big thematic differences between thinking in pictures or not thinking in pictures. Then just very quickly, the third way is using your pupil. So people will know that if you look at a bright light, if you look at the sun, which you shouldn't, your pupil will constrict. to protect the neurons in your eye, less light in. It turns out that if you imagine bright things or dark things, your pupil also responds. So you get people into a dark room and you say imagine you can just use simple shapes or you can use real objects. Imagine this under bright lights, a bright square or a dark square.
稍后我们会看到，这种情感反应是“用图片思考”与“不用图片思考”之间最大的主题差异之一。然后，第三种方法是使用瞳孔。人们会知道，如果你看强光，如果你看太阳——虽然你不应该这样做——你的瞳孔会收缩，以保护眼睛里的神经元，减少光线进入。事实证明，如果你想象明亮的事物或黑暗的事物，你的瞳孔也会做出反应。所以你让人们进入一个黑暗的房间，你说“想象一下”——你可以使用简单的形状，也可以使用真实的物体——“在强光下想象这个，一个明亮的方块或一个黑暗的方块”。
And you'll see that people will also constrict when they're imagining the bright square. So you can measure this with a little infrared camera quite easily, and it turns out that's also a nice way to measure mental imagery. If you don't have mental imagery and you try and do that task, your pupil doesn't respond. Interestingly though, there's a nice control in that experiment that you can get people trying to imagine one object, two objects, three objects or four objects, and the sort of mental load is more with more objects. And we see. see that the pupil also responds to this mental load and we see that response in both groups that those with visual imagery and those with AFentasia. So that's a nice way to control because
你会看到，当人们想象明亮的方块时，他们的瞳孔也会收缩。你可以用一个小红外摄像头很容易地测量到这一点，事实证明这也是衡量心理意象的好方法。如果你没有心理意象，而你尝试做这个任务，你的瞳孔就不会做出反应。有趣的是，那个实验中有一个很好的对照，你可以让人们尝试想象一个物体、两个物体、三个物体或四个物体，物体越多，心理负荷就越大。我们看到瞳孔也会对这种心理负荷做出反应，而且我们在两组人中都看到了这种反应，无论是那些有视觉意象的人，还是那些患有心盲症的人。这是一个很好的对照，因为
many people would say, oh, how do you know that people with A Fantasia just aren't trying? And so this sort of set size effect of the number of objects is a nice way to provide evidence that yes, people with A Fantasia are indeed trying. We can see this is different. So that's really the three ways of measuring imagery. Of course, you can use brain scanning, fMRI to look at the visual response in visual areas, but that's much slower and much more expensive. But speaking of brains and fMRIs, what do we know about what's happening in the brains of people who have a Fantasia? Do we have information from these brain studies? Yeah, we have. We've got sort of, we've done brain stimulation studies and functional magnetic resonance imaging studies. We've done
很多人会说：“你怎么知道患有心盲症的人不是没在尝试呢？”所以这种物体数量的设置大小效应，是一个很好的证据，证明患有心盲症的人确实在尝试。我们可以看到这是不同的。这就是衡量意象的三种方法。当然，你可以使用脑部扫描，即 fMRI 来观察视觉区域的视觉反应，但这要慢得多，也昂贵得多。说到大脑和 fMRI，我们对心盲症患者大脑中发生的事情了解多少？我们有来自这些脑部研究的信息吗？是的，我们有。我们做过脑部刺激研究和功能性磁共振成像研究。我们还做过
sort of anatomical studies as well. So first up, we have evidence that the size of visual cortex, so if everyone remembers the cerebral cortex around the outside is this big sheet, but it's all sort of scrunched up to fit inside the skull. Now, you can measure that in a brain scanner, and then you can kind of flatten it out and measure the size of different brain areas. And we've done that with visual cortex, the part of the back of the brain, and we find that those with a sort of, smaller visual cortex tend to have stronger mental imagery, which is interesting in itself. And there's also evidence that there are genes which contribute to the size of visual cortex. So there's also emerging evidence that there might be some genetic components to Afantasia.
解剖学研究。首先，我们有证据表明视觉皮层的大小——如果大家还记得，大脑皮层外围是一大片，但为了塞进头骨里都皱在一起了。现在，你可以在脑部扫描仪中测量它，然后你可以把它展平，测量不同大脑区域的大小。我们对大脑后部的视觉皮层做了这项研究，发现那些视觉皮层较小的人往往有更强的心理意象，这本身就很有趣。而且还有证据表明，有一些基因会影响视觉皮层的大小。因此，也有越来越多的证据表明心盲症可能存在一些遗传成分。
We've also done research looking at the cortical excitability of visual cortex. So a nice way to think about that is that there's all the neurons in your visual cortex. Neurons are never just quiet and doing nothing. They're always sort of what seems like random firing. There's this baseline activity. We find that that baseline activity is also related to visual imagery strength. So the noisier those visual neurons are, the weaker the imagery tends to be, and the quieter they are, the stronger and clearer mental imagery seems to be.
我们还进行了研究，观察视觉皮层的皮层兴奋性。思考这个问题的一个好方法是，视觉皮层里有所有的神经元。神经元从来不会安静地什么都不做。它们总是处于一种看起来像是随机放电的状态。存在这种基线活动。我们发现这种基线活动也与视觉意象强度有关。视觉神经元越嘈杂，意象往往越弱；它们越安静，心理意象似乎就越强、越清晰。
Now, we can measure that with TMS, transcranial magnetic stimulation, but we've also done a sort of causative manipulation of that by using a type of brain stimulation which runs off a small battery, TDCS, a transcranial direct current stimulation. And when we do that, we can up or down regulate that sort of resting state cortical excitability. And we see that when we do that, that imagery can be, we can make it stronger or weaker. These are not massive effects. They're quite small effects, but they are reliable. And we're measuring these effects, using that binocular ivory method I mentioned earlier. Then more recently, there's been a bunch of research we've done
现在，我们可以用 TMS（经颅磁刺激）来测量这一点，但我们也通过使用一种由小电池供电的脑部刺激——TDCS（经颅直流电刺激）——对它进行了因果操纵。当我们这样做时，我们可以上调或下调那种静息状态的皮层兴奋性。我们看到，当我们这样做时，意象可以变得更强或更弱。这些影响并不巨大，它们相当小，但很可靠。我们正在使用我之前提到的双眼竞争方法来测量这些影响。最近，我们还做了一系列研究，
looking at trying to decode mental images in visual cortex. So we've known for a while that if you have mental imagery when you imagine something, just like when you look at something, you can decode that pattern of activity and know what someone's looking at using sort of more modern fMRI techniques, algorithms and a bit of AI sometimes. Now it turns out, interestingly, you can also do that in people with a Fantasia, which is kind of strange because they're saying they don't have any imagery, they're trying, there's no conscious experience of imagery, but it seems like there's a decodable pattern in their visual cortex. So then the question then becomes, what is that pattern?
试图解码视觉皮层中的心理意象。我们早就知道，如果你有心理意象，当你想象某样东西时，就像你看到某样东西时一样，你可以使用更现代的 fMRI 技术、算法和有时一点人工智能来解码那种活动模式，并知道某人在看什么。现在有趣的是，你也可以在心盲症患者身上做到这一点，这很奇怪，因为他们说他们没有任何意象，他们正在尝试，没有意象的意识体验，但视觉皮层中似乎存在一种可解码的模式。那么问题就变成了，那种模式是什么？
Why is it not conscious? and that has started sort of these debates are around this idea of unconscious imagery and maybe there could be two different types of visual aphantasia some sort of what people might call like a true affantasia with zero imagery and another type where there is sort of
为什么它没有进入意识？这引发了关于“无意识意象”的辩论，也许可能存在两种不同类型的心盲症：一种是人们可能称之为“真正的心盲症”，即零意象；另一种是存在某种
some residual representation and for unknown reasons at this stage that representation remains unconscious but maybe people can't pay attention to it or for some other reason the format is slightly different and it just remains unconscious. So that's where things are out at the moment and people are sort of getting excited about how to then sort of probe this idea further of unconscious imagery. There does seem to be other evidence we've collected from non-A Fantasia research that
残留表征，但由于目前尚不清楚的原因，该表征保持在无意识状态。也许人们无法关注它，或者由于某种其他原因，格式略有不同，它只是保持在无意识状态。这就是目前的情况，人们开始对如何进一步探索这种“无意识意象”的想法感到兴奋。我们从非心盲症研究中收集到的其他证据似乎表明，
if you do have visual imagery, you can have unconscious imagery, just like you can have unconscious visual perception, kind of a tangent, but it does seem to be there. So it could be that there is something similar happening with Afantasia. Do people with Afantasia dream? It turns out, yeah, all we have at this stage is questionnaire data. We haven't done the study that we'd love to do, which is a proper sleep study, where we get people in the lab and they have a sleep lab or they sleep all night, and we wake them up and monitor their brain activity.
如果你确实有视觉意象，你也可以有无意识意象，就像你可以有无意识的视觉感知一样，这有点跑题了，但它似乎确实存在。所以心盲症可能也发生了类似的事情。心盲症患者会做梦吗？事实证明，是的，我们目前拥有的只有问卷数据。我们还没有做我们想做的研究，即适当的睡眠研究，让人们进入实验室，在睡眠实验室里睡一整晚，我们唤醒他们并监测他们的大脑活动。
But looking at the questionnaire data, it seems that some do, some don't. So when you average all the data, you do see significant differences in the amount. of dreaming, the sensory qualities of the dream. But to really understand the data, you're going to kind of dig more on an individual level where some people report they have no memory of dreams. Some people report still dreams with emotional content but less visual. Some people report sort of black and white dreams. And so there's kind of a mixture state there. But there are certainly people that have a Fantasia and do report dreaming. What about reading? I mean, if you're going to read fiction, you are going to have a mental image of what's going on in the story.
但查看问卷数据，似乎有些人会做梦，有些人不会。所以当你平均所有数据时，你会看到梦的数量、梦的感官质量存在显著差异。但要真正理解这些数据，你必须在个体层面进行深入挖掘，有些人报告说他们对梦没有任何记忆。有些人报告说梦里仍有情感内容，但视觉效果较少。有些人报告说梦是黑白的。所以那里存在一种混合状态。但肯定有患有心盲症的人报告说他们会做梦。阅读呢？我的意思是，如果你要读小说，你脑海中肯定会有故事正在发生的情景。
I mean, the people with Afantasia find reading fiction in particular so boring that they just can't do it? Well, not so boring that I never read a book, but there is emerging evidence. And I think some papers are about to come out on this where, yeah, the, you know, if you think about that study I mentioned before where reading, you know, emotional content, the skin conductance response was different. So you can think about that, you know, to reading an exciting or scary novel. Without those pictures in your mind, the experience is going to be, I don't like to use a word lacking, but at least in terms of emotional content, it probably will be lacking. I don't
我的意思是，患有心盲症的人是否觉得读小说特别无聊，以至于他们根本读不下去？嗯，还没无聊到我从不读书的地步，但确实有新的证据出现。我想有些论文即将发表，是的，如果你想想我之前提到的那个研究，阅读情感内容时，皮肤电导反应是不同的。所以你可以想象，阅读一本令人兴奋或恐怖的小说。如果没有脑海中的那些画面，体验将会——我不喜欢用“缺乏”这个词——但至少在情感内容方面，它可能会有所欠缺。我不想
want to make claims in other areas. And so because of that, yeah, there is some evidence now that people with A Fantasia enjoy reading a little bit less when it comes to fiction or get a little bit less drawn into the stories. And that's sort of that theme I mentioned earlier, that this idea of imagery as this virtual reality simulator that can amplify emotions. And so there's sort of this interesting link between thoughts and the emotional responses, the emotional parts of our brain, and imagery seems to sit there in the middle. And it's almost like if you have imagery, it can kind of trick the emotional parts in your brain to thinking the content of imagery is actually happening, and so it responds more. So I mentioned that skin conductance response.
在其他领域做出断言。正因为如此，确实有一些证据表明，心盲症患者在阅读小说时享受程度稍低，或者更容易被故事吸引的程度稍低。这就是我之前提到的那个主题，即意象作为一种可以放大情感的虚拟现实模拟器。所以思维与情感反应、大脑情感部分之间存在这种有趣的联系，而意象似乎就处于中间。这几乎就像是，如果你有意象，它就能欺骗大脑中的情感部分，让它认为意象的内容正在真实发生，从而做出更强烈的反应。所以我提到了那个皮肤电导反应。
We have done studies looking at risk perception, looking at empathy, looking at mind wandering, and we've done studies looking at models of PTSD. So PTSD, lab-based models of PTSD, where people come into the lab and watch a real sort of pretty unpleasant video, and then we send them home with an app that sort of they monitor every time they think about that video or have an image pop into the head or have any thoughts pop into the head. And we see stark differences there between those that have imagery and Afantasia. And when they do think about that video, the emotional response and how disruptive it is to their life is very different. So across all those examples, sort of the empathy, the mind wandering, some moral dilemma stuff we're doing now, it seems that this emotional response to thoughts, thought simulations, is just different
我们已经进行了研究，观察风险感知、同理心、走神，我们还研究了 PTSD 模型。所以 PTSD，基于实验室的 PTSD 模型，人们来到实验室观看一段相当令人不快的视频，然后我们让他们带着一个应用程序回家，监测他们每次想到那个视频、脑海中弹出图像或弹出任何想法的情况。我们看到有意象的人和心盲症患者之间存在显著差异。当他们想到那个视频时，情感反应以及它对生活的干扰程度是非常不同的。所以通过所有这些例子——同理心、走神、我们现在正在做的一些道德困境研究——似乎对想法、思维模拟的情感反应，在
with or without imagery. So sort of from anxiety through to basically anything that you think would benefit or be different with a sort of virtual simulation of the thing, sensory simulation, does seem to be different. And that would include, you know, addiction and cravings, you know, a lot of things there. So that is probably the biggest difference we see in thinking with images. or thinking without images. I am wondering if there's a relationship between Afantasia and prosopagnosia or face blindness.
有无意象的情况下就是不同的。所以从焦虑到基本上任何你认为会受益于某种虚拟模拟、感官模拟的事物，似乎都是不同的。这可能包括成瘾和渴望，那里有很多东西。所以这可能是我们在“用图片思考”或“不用图片思考”中看到的最大差异。我想知道心盲症和面孔失认症（脸盲症）之间是否存在关系。
If you don't have a mental image of the things you have experienced, does that affect whether you can recognize people or places you've seen before? There are studies, we've done studies on episodic memory, so lifelong memories, and we find that using this sort of interview-style techniques, where you've got to remember events that happened, you know, a month ago, six months ago, years, 10 years ago, that those with Afantasia recall less details about very similar events compared to those with imagery. Of course, the vividness, the emotionality of those experiences are also different.
如果你对自己经历过的事物没有心理意象，这是否会影响你识别以前见过的人或地方的能力？有研究，我们对情景记忆——即终身记忆——进行了研究，我们发现使用这种访谈式技术，你需要记住一个月前、六个月前、几年前、十年前发生的事件，那些患有心盲症的人与有意象的人相比，回忆起的事件细节较少。当然，这些体验的生动性和情感性也是不同的。
But the details thing is kind of quite interesting. And it's not devastatingly different. I'm like there's no details. There's still plenty of details. But it is significantly different or there's significantly more details if you have imagery. So the memory of experiences in our lives does seem to be different, you know, if you have an image attached to that memory or can recreate that image. I think there's some evidence potentially linking prosopagnosiae. I don't know how strong that evidence is.
但细节方面的事情相当有趣。它并不是毁灭性地不同。并不是说完全没有细节。仍然有很多细节。但它确实有显著差异，或者说如果你有意象，细节会显著更多。所以我们生活中经历的记忆似乎确实是不同的，如果你有附着在记忆上的意象，或者能够重现那个意象的话。我认为有一些证据可能将面孔失认症联系起来。我不知道那个证据有多强。
I have certainly come across individuals, not many, just like two or three, who claim to have sort of a very specific version of Afantasia, which is face-specific. face specific. So it's kind of like a prosopagnosia version of Afantasia. They say they can imagine, you know, their dog's face, fine, but they can't imagine human faces. They can still recognize them, but they just can't imagine them. So it's not just prosopagnosia, it's like an imagery version of prosopagnosia. Again, only a handful of cases I've seen of that. But yeah, there certainly does seem to be these differences with memory and the amount of information you can recall. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Pearson about what it's like to have hyperfantasia
我确实遇到过一些人，不多，也就两三个，他们声称患有一种非常特殊的心盲症，即“面孔特异性”心盲症。所以这有点像心盲症的面孔失认症版本。他们说他们可以想象他们狗的脸，没问题，但他们无法想象人脸。他们仍然可以认出他们，但就是无法想象他们。所以这不仅仅是面孔失认症，它就像是面孔失认症的意象版本。同样，我只见过少数几个这样的案例。但是的，记忆和你能回忆的信息量确实存在这些差异。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与 Pearson 博士谈谈患有“超心盲症”（hyperphantasia）是什么感觉，
or extremely vivid, detailed mental imagery. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set For only $499. This Memorial Day, get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. Lost supplies last.
或者极其生动、详细的心理意象。你的夏天从家得宝（Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四炉头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止。
Priced invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost!
价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够去迷路了！
Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay.
或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可节省 20%，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要优惠，而不是惊喜时，你住哪里很重要。
Hilton, for the stay. Let's talk about the other side of the coin, which is the people who have constant images or a hyperfantasia where it's extremely vivid and detailed in their minds all the time. I mean, how common is that? And do we all just, sort of fall somewhere in between one or the other? Yeah, so there does seem to be almost a
希尔顿，为了住宿。让我们谈谈硬币的另一面，也就是那些拥有持续意象或“超心盲症”的人，他们的脑海中一直有极其生动和详细的意象。我的意思是，这有多普遍？我们是否都只是落在两者之间的某个位置？是的，似乎几乎存在一个
normal distribution, or at least something that's shaped like that. It's whereas there's this sort of bell curve where most people fall in the middle somewhere, and then you have these tails that get thin on the end. There's been much less research done on what's called hyperfantasia, or if you go back a few decades, it was called idatic imagery. So there was a whole field of research into what's called idatic imagery in children. Back sort of last century, looking at this idea that children under 11, under 10 years old, had much stronger imagery than something would happen during their teenage years and the imagery would get sort of get weaker.
正态分布，或者至少是形状类似的东西。它就像一个钟形曲线，大多数人落在中间的某个地方，然后你有这些在末端变细的尾巴。关于所谓的“超心盲症”的研究要少得多，或者如果你回到几十年前，它被称为“遗觉意象”（eidetic imagery）。所以上个世纪曾有一个完整的研究领域，研究儿童的遗觉意象。当时在研究 11 岁、10 岁以下的儿童比青少年时期有更强的意象，随着年龄增长意象会变弱。
Again, some of that research is a bit dated now. We don't have the same techniques for measuring these things that we, you know, they didn't have those techniques back then. So we don't know a lot about that using modern techniques. Because Afantasia gets a lot of media attention, we have huge databases with many thousands of people that have Afantasia. But in comparison, we have a very small database for those that have hyperfantasia. And again, it's clearer and easier to define a Fantasia as the complete absence.
同样，其中一些研究现在有点过时了。我们没有像现在这样衡量这些事物的技术，他们当时没有那些技术。所以我们对使用现代技术了解这些并不多。因为心盲症受到了很多媒体关注，我们拥有拥有数千名心盲症患者的庞大数据库。但相比之下，我们对于那些拥有超心盲症的人的数据库非常小。而且，将心盲症定义为完全缺失确实更清晰、更容易。
You know, you have imagery or you don't have imagery. There's kind of a step function there. Whereas it's harder to define the upper end of this hyperfantasia. When does strong imagery become hyper or not? It can be a bit of an arbitrary cutoff. And I think as we do more research into this, we will end up to free. finding it more to do with things like false memories. So I know some people with very strong imagery who will literally have confusions about
你要么有意象，要么没有意象。那里有一个阶梯函数。而定义超心盲症的上限则更难。强烈的意象何时变成“超”？这可能是一个有点武断的界限。我认为随着我们对此进行更多研究，我们最终会将其更多地与“虚假记忆”之类的事情联系起来。我知道一些拥有非常强烈意象的人，他们真的会混淆
whether they imagined a scenario or whether it actually happened. There's a reason that most of us will forget our dreams, so we don't have reality confusion with our dreams, but if you have very strong imagery, and then you remember that, not only could it sort of affect your sort of eyewitness memory of an event, you could sort of that you imagine that something and then that gets reconsolidated back into the original memory, you can also just have confusion between whether something actually happened at all and the visual image. So we've done research into individuals with Parkinson's disease who have visual hallucinations, and we find that those with visual hallucinations have very strong imagery as measured using the bonocular ivory
他们是想象了一个场景，还是它真的发生了。我们大多数人会忘记梦境是有原因的，所以我们不会对梦境产生现实混淆，但如果你有非常强烈的意象，然后你记住了它，它不仅会影响你对事件的目击记忆——你可能想象了某事，然后它被重新整合回原始记忆中——你还可能在某事是否真的发生过与视觉意象之间产生混淆。所以我们对患有帕金森病并出现视觉幻觉的个体进行了研究，我们发现那些出现视觉幻觉的人，使用双眼竞争技术测量，拥有非常强烈的意象。
technique. We also see people who have schizophrenia have not only the auditory stuff, but they have very strong visual imagery. And also we see this trend in schizophreny individuals as well. So on the spectrum towards schizophrenia, we see that this association between strong imagery and anxiety and PTSD as well. So there's this kind of theme emerging there that some psychological and neurological disorders are associated with stronger mental imagery. And so you could make the case that everything else being equal, if you had to choose between very, very strong imagery and very, very weak or zero imagery, you may actually want to choose Afantasia just because of this association
我们还看到患有精神分裂症的人不仅有听觉方面的问题，而且有非常强烈的视觉意象。我们也在精神分裂症个体中看到了这种趋势。所以，在迈向精神分裂症的谱系上，我们看到了这种强烈意象与焦虑和 PTSD 之间的关联。所以那里出现了一个主题，即一些心理和神经疾病与更强烈的心理意象有关。因此，你可以提出这样的观点：在其他条件相同的情况下，如果你必须在非常、非常强烈的意象和非常、非常微弱或零意象之间做出选择，你实际上可能想选择心盲症，仅仅是因为这种与
with psychological and neurological disorders. But we know less about the high-end hyperphantasia than the Afantasia at this stage. So we don't know a lot, but I've certainly met individuals who say they can they can sort of replay a whole film and they swear to me their conscious experience is like watching it on an iPad. It's that clear. Now, I absolutely can't do that. So it's, it is hard for me to believe that, but they, I've only met one or two people that say that and we haven't had a chance to study them in detail yet. But there are seemingly individuals who can do that. So, So yeah, that's a big difference from no imagery at all.
心理和神经疾病的关联。但目前我们对高端的超心盲症的了解比心盲症要少。所以我们了解不多，但我确实见过一些人，他们说他们可以重播整部电影，他们向我发誓他们的意识体验就像在 iPad 上观看一样。就是那么清晰。现在，我绝对做不到这一点。所以，这对我来说很难相信，但我只见过一两个人这么说，我们还没有机会详细研究他们。但似乎确实有人能做到这一点。所以，是的，这与完全没有意象有很大不同。
Does AFantasia exist only for visual images? I guess my question is, is it possible to have the equivalent of AFantasia for other senses, say being unable to hear music in your mind or recall a smell or a texture? Yeah, great question, Kim. Yeah, absolutely. So it does, it's not just visual. You can have full multisensory Aphantasia. So we've done some research where we measured a few thousand people
心盲症只存在于视觉意象中吗？我想我的问题是，是否可能在其他感官上也存在心盲症的等价物，比如无法在脑海中听到音乐，或回忆起气味或质地？是的，好问题，Kim。是的，绝对可以。所以它不仅仅是视觉的。你可以拥有完全的多感官心盲症。我们进行了一些研究，测量了几千人，
and ran a sort of clustering analysis, a bunch of different clustering analysis to see the groupings. And we found that, yeah, most people who had AFantasia tended to have this full multisensory Aphantasia. But there was also a significant group that just had pure visual. And then we found all the other groupings you could imagine, but in very small quantities or proportions. So you could have a pure auditory, Afantasia, you could have auditory and visual,
并运行了一种聚类分析，一堆不同的聚类分析来查看分组。我们发现，是的，大多数患有心盲症的人往往患有这种完全的多感官心盲症。但也有一个显著的群体只是纯视觉的。然后我们发现了你能想象到的所有其他分组，但数量或比例非常小。所以你可以有纯听觉心盲症，你可以有听觉和视觉，
but they were very small groups compared to the sort of larger groups of pure visual or pure multisensory across all the sensors. And so there is a bias there in that the databases and the people we test have heard about Afantasia as a visual thing. So of course there's going to be more people on the database that have visual, Afantasia, but the clustering do exist there. and you can also drill down and there's people that have sort of auditory a Fantasia and then there's also a subgroup which might be able to imagine music and sounds
但与纯视觉或跨所有感官的纯多感官的大群体相比，它们是非常小的群体。所以那里存在一种偏差，因为数据库和我们测试的人听说过心盲症是一种视觉事物。所以当然，数据库中会有更多患有视觉心盲症的人，但聚类确实存在。你也可以深入挖掘，有些人患有听觉心盲症，然后还有一个亚组可能能够想象音乐和声音，
but don't have an sort of inner mind's voice if you're like when they read they don't hear the mental version of words being read to them they can't talk to themselves and that's actually started to grow into its own sort of subfield now of sort of the inner workings of the minds and the inner voice but absolutely yeah imagery can be a across any of the senses, which is pretty interesting in itself. And I often have thought about this, we've written about this a bit, that you don't really have a version of multi-sensory blindness, for example. I can't think of an individual in history that has had no sensory abilities across all
但没有所谓的“内心声音”，如果你愿意的话，当他们阅读时，他们听不到文字被读给他们的心理版本，他们无法对自己说话，这实际上已经开始发展成为自己的一个子领域，即思维的内在运作和内在声音，但绝对是的，意象可以跨越任何感官，这本身就非常有趣。我经常思考这个问题，我们对此写过一点，你并没有多感官失明之类的版本。我想不出历史上有什么人拥有跨越所有感官的感官能力缺失。
their senses. No sight, no sound, no touch, no taste, no smell. Like, I don't think we've ever had that. But the fact that you can have that in Afantasia already tells you something interesting about the differences between mental imagery across the senses and sensory perception, that there is something more central going on there, that you can have all these things not existing together. Let me switch topics here a little bit.
他们的感官。没有视觉、没有听觉、没有触觉、没有味觉、没有嗅觉。我觉得我们以前从未遇到过这种情况。但事实上，在心盲症（Afantasia）中你可以拥有这种体验，这本身就揭示了感官心理意象与感官知觉之间差异的一些有趣之处，即在大脑中存在着更核心的机制，使得这些感官体验可以同时缺失。让我稍微转换一下话题。
I know you've studied the connection between Afantasia and creativity. What have you found? What is the relationship? Yeah, so we've done a bunch of research on this. We haven't yet published them. It's kind of a bit of a pipeline in the lab, a clogged up pipeline of, publications at present. But in some, we found that there was no clear differences between those that have a Fantasia and those that have imagery in the sort of the classic ways of trying to measure
我知道你研究过心盲症与创造力之间的联系。你发现了什么？它们之间是什么关系？是的，我们在这方面做了很多研究。我们还没有发表这些成果。目前实验室里有一堆积压的论文等待发表。但在一些研究中，我们发现，在衡量创造力的经典方式上，心盲症患者与拥有心理意象的人之间并没有明显的差异。
creativity. And this is this divergent thinking, tasks like, you know, here's a brick. How many different ways can you, could you use the brick? And then you have independent people score that on, you know, how creative it is and also how many different uses and things like that. So despite what people think and say that A Fantasia is holding back their creativity at work or something. The data doesn't really support that because we didn't see any differences. And then having said that, you know, we've had A Fantasia visual art exhibitions. Ed Capable, who co-founded Pixar and ran that and then ran Disney Studios for many years. A friend of mine, he has A Fantasia.
这就是发散性思维，比如任务是：给你一块砖头，你能想出多少种不同的用法？然后由独立评分员根据创造力程度以及用途的多样性等指标进行打分。所以，尽管人们认为心盲症会阻碍工作中的创造力，但数据并不支持这一点，因为我们没有观察到任何差异。话虽如此，我们举办过心盲症视觉艺术展。皮克斯（Pixar）的联合创始人、曾长期执掌皮克斯和迪士尼工作室的艾德·卡特姆（Ed Catmull）也是我的朋友，他就是一位心盲症患者。
So he was crucial early on and coming up with some of the ideas and methods for doing computer design. using these sort of geometric shapes to define a square or a sphere. And he said that if he could visualize the shapes, he probably wouldn't have come up with this mathematical geometry, these little triangles and things to describe these shapes. And so he almost credits A Fantasia and helping him with some of these breakthroughs in these sort of 3D designs. Also one of their top animators,
他在早期构思计算机设计的一些理念和方法时起到了至关重要的作用，比如使用几何形状来定义正方形或球体。他说，如果他能进行视觉化想象，他可能就不会想出这种数学几何方法，即用这些小三角形之类的东西来描述形状。因此，他几乎将这些3D设计领域的突破归功于心盲症。此外，他们的一位顶级动画师，
I'm blanking on the gentleman's name, but he was one of the top, the person who did a lot of the little mermaid designs for the characters. He has Afantasia. And so I don't want anyone to think that, you know, if you have Afentasia, it's some barrier to being creative or starting an enterprise or a business or any of these things. It does not seem to be the case. So I think it's important to get that out there.
我一时想不起这位先生的名字，但他是一位顶尖人物，负责了《小美人鱼》中许多角色的设计。他也是心盲症患者。所以我不想让任何人认为，如果你有心盲症，这就是发挥创造力、创业或从事任何事业的障碍。事实似乎并非如此。所以我认为把这一点传达出来很重要。
Yeah, and I didn't want to give the impression either that A Fantasia is some kind of a disorder that needs to be fixed. I mean, it seems from what I've been reading anyway, and you would know better than I, that people who have it don't feel that they're in any way held back in. in life, but I'm wondering if there are interventions, so if somebody said, yeah, I'd like to know what it's like to have visual internal life. Is there anything that can be done to help with that?
是的，我也不想给人留下心盲症是一种需要“修复”的疾病的印象。我的意思是，根据我的阅读，而且你比我更了解，那些患有心盲症的人并不觉得他们在生活中受到了任何阻碍。但我很好奇是否有干预措施，如果有人说：“是的，我想体验一下拥有视觉内心世界是什么感觉”，有什么办法可以帮助他们吗？
Like I said, I mentioned earlier, we've done the study using that sort of that type of brain stimulation where we have up or down regulated imagery strength. All those participants had some form of imagery to begin with. Now, separately, we've done a five-day experiment where we had people come into the lab and practice their imagery every day for one hour for five days in a row, and while they were practicing, you know, we were measuring it using that binocular ivory technique. And we didn't really see any improvement over that time.
就像我之前提到的，我们做过一项研究，利用那种脑刺激技术来上调或下调意象强度。所有参与者在实验开始时都具备某种形式的意象能力。另外，我们还做过一个为期五天的实验，让参与者每天到实验室练习一小时意象，连续五天。在他们练习时，我们使用双眼竞争技术进行测量。但在那段时间里，我们并没有看到明显的改善。
Now, that doesn't mean it's not trainable. The thing with brain stimulation is it's not magically going to tell you how to create a mental image. In the same way that if you wanted to learn a new language, let's say you can't speak Chinese and you want to learn Chinese, while I can stimulate the language areas of your brain, and that would improve your performance somewhat, it's not going to magically give you the ability and the knowledge to speak Chinese. So I think the answer may be in combining practice
但这并不意味着它无法训练。脑刺激的问题在于，它不会神奇地告诉你如何创造心理意象。就像如果你想学习一门新语言，比如你不会说中文，你想学中文，虽然我可以刺激你大脑中的语言区，这会提高你的表现，但它不会神奇地赋予你说中文的能力和知识。所以我认为答案可能在于将练习与脑刺激结合起来。
with brain stimulation. Now, there is an emerging trend that has not, to my knowledge, been studied scientifically yet of this image streaming technique that came from photography where people would first have their eyes open and look at a room and then verbally out loud describe the visual details as much as possible. And they do this over and over. And this came from photography where they were trying to design and the right way to set up a photograph.
目前出现了一种趋势，据我所知尚未经过科学研究，即源自摄影领域的“意象流”（image streaming）技术。人们首先睁开眼睛观察一个房间，然后尽可能大声地用语言描述视觉细节。他们反复这样做。这源于摄影界，当时他们试图设计和确定布置照片的最佳方式。
And then the idea is then you close your eyes and try and do it by memory. And it's important, apparently, that you do this out loud. So there's a few groups online, in particular on YouTube now who are talking about that as a way to train mental imagery or give people mental imagery experience. Now, I know some people who have tried that and they haven't really noticed much difference. Some people claim that they have. And so again, it may be the case that some people who have Afentasia have some residual imagery and that can be trained up and part of that equation might be simply teaching people what to pay attention to because they don't even know what imagery is in the first place.
然后，接下来的步骤是闭上眼睛，尝试通过记忆来完成。显然，大声说出来很重要。现在网上有一些群体，特别是在YouTube上，正在讨论将其作为训练心理意象或让人们获得心理意象体验的方法。我知道有些人尝试过，但并没有感觉到太大差异。有些人声称他们有效果。所以，再次强调，可能有些心盲症患者确实残留了一些意象能力，可以通过训练提升，而其中的一部分可能仅仅是教人们如何去注意，因为他们甚至不知道什么是意象。
I should also mention there's two published case studies, they're retrospective studies, from people who have been part of psychedelic research. At least two of those individuals, and by retrospective they won't set out beforehand to study mental imagery, they kind of discovered this along the way. And so it does rely on their memory of what the imagery was like before they took part
我还应该提到有两个已发表的案例研究，它们是回顾性研究，对象是参与过迷幻药研究的人。至少有两个人，之所以说是回顾性，是因为他们事先并没有打算研究心理意象，而是在过程中偶然发现的。因此，这依赖于他们对参与迷幻药研究之前意象体验的记忆。
in the psychedelic research. And they say that not only did they have the experience of imagery during the effect of the molecule, but that lasted afterwards as well. and that has given them imagery. Now because it's just these two case studies, we have no idea whether these are, you know, two out of a thousand people or would this work for everyone.
他们说，不仅在药物作用期间有了意象体验，而且这种体验在之后也持续存在，这赋予了他们意象能力。由于这只是两个案例研究，我们不知道这是否是千分之一的概率，还是对每个人都有效。
I certainly have talked to people who have taken part in psychedelic research and have Afentasia and it didn't change their imagery. So I don't think it's going to work for everyone. But there's some interesting things possibly emerging there because we know that psychedelics will do a few things, but one of the things it does is put your brain to this very plastic state where it can rewire quite quickly. And so that's very interesting in respect to Afantasia and mental imagery. So just to wrap up, what might studying Afantasia and Hyperfantasia tell us more broadly about how the human mind works?
我确实和一些参与过迷幻药研究的心盲症患者谈过，他们的意象能力并没有改变。所以我认为这不会对每个人都有效。但其中可能出现了一些有趣的现象，因为我们知道迷幻药会产生一些作用，其中之一就是让大脑进入一种高度可塑的状态，可以很快地重连。因此，这在心盲症和心理意象方面非常有趣。最后总结一下，研究心盲症和超意象症（Hyperfantasia）能让我们更广泛地了解人类思维是如何运作的吗？
I think first up, it's a really powerful and nice example of cognitive and neural diversity across the human experience. Another way to phrase all this would be that the format, right? The format of your thoughts does change your life. And it changes the way you think. It changes how much you might donate to a charity. It changes your risk perception. So any time your thoughts will take on the format of a depictive picture in your brain and mind, then that will nudge you and change the way you think,
我认为首先，这是一个关于人类认知和神经多样性的非常有力且美妙的例子。换句话说，思维的格式确实会改变你的生活。它改变了你的思考方式。它改变了你向慈善机构捐款的金额。它改变了你的风险感知。所以，每当你的思想在大脑中以描绘性图像的格式呈现时，它就会引导并改变你的思考方式，
almost like a cognitive bias or a nudge in that language. So that in itself is really interesting. I think also it teaches us about the internal types of consciousness research. I've also always been fascinated by consciousness studies. I think imagery is one of the ways to study internal consciousness. In visual neuroscience, one of the things that's really hard to study is feedback signals. So we know that there's more signals that go backwards, if you like, in the brain than forwards. So forwards means from my retina and my eye, back to visual cortex and up to the higher levels of the brain.
就像认知偏差或语言中的“助推”（nudge）一样。所以这本身就非常有趣。我认为它也让我们了解了内部意识研究。我一直对意识研究很着迷。我认为意象是研究内部意识的方法之一。在视觉神经科学中，很难研究的一件事是反馈信号。我们知道，大脑中向后传递的信号比向前传递的信号多。向前意味着从视网膜和眼睛，传回视觉皮层，再传到大脑的高级区域。
But there's more connections that go backwards in many parts of the brain. We don't know a lot about what those do. And it's very hard to study. But voluntary visual imagery is one of the few cases where you're going to have the eyes closed, have no visual stimulation, have someone imagine something, and then study those feedback signals that are involved in visualizing mental imagery in a very pure isolated format. By that very definition, we stand to learn a lot about sensory perception
但在大脑的许多部分，向后传递的连接更多。我们对它们的功能知之甚少，而且很难研究。但自愿的视觉意象是少数几种情况之一，你可以闭上眼睛，没有任何视觉刺激，让某人想象某物，然后在非常纯粹、孤立的格式下研究参与视觉意象的反馈信号。根据这个定义，我们有望通过研究心理意象来了解很多关于感官知觉的知识。
from studying mental imagery. And if I want to be controversial and probably annoying my colleagues in the vision science community, I would say the key to understanding vision would actually be one of the keys to understanding vision would be visual imagery. And so, yeah, the neurodiversity,
如果我想引起争议，可能会惹恼视觉科学界的同事，我会说理解视觉的关键实际上——或者说关键之一——就是视觉意象。所以，是的，神经多样性、理解反馈、理解意识，所有这些我认为最终都对科学、心理学和神经科学做出了非常重要的贡献。
the understanding feedback, understanding consciousness, all those things I think end up being really important contributions to science in general, to psychology and neuroscience. Well, Dr. Pearson, I want to thank you for joining me. This has been really interesting. I think you're working in a very unusual part of psychology.
好的，皮尔逊博士，感谢你接受我的采访。这非常有趣。我认为你在心理学中一个非常不同寻常的领域工作。
So thanks so much for sharing your knowledge. My pleasure, Kim. Great to talk today. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review.
非常感谢你分享你的知识。不客气，金。今天谈话很愉快。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请订阅并留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items,
如果你对未来的节目有意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听。美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。放松一下，让 Ralph's 的配送服务来处理你本周的杂货采购吧。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，
then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然后核对你的清单并仔细挑选每一件商品。接着我们打包好，并在短短30分钟内送达，让你确信这就是你订购的商品。Ralph's 的配送和自提服务，以你的方式提供新鲜杂货。现在，你的第一笔配送或自提订单可节省20美元。Ralph's，为每个人提供新鲜。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。